vous êtes triste et solitaire vous
enviez les couples qui s'aiment mais
vous hésitez à vous jeter à l'eau de
peur d'êtrecuit timide de tous les pays
réjouissez-vous le bip bip de l'amour
est arrivé c'est le flashing ça se porte
sur soi n'importe quand n'importe où et
quand vous croisez un autre ou une autre
possesseur de flashing ça aé un bip
sonore autrement dit le flashing ça
permet de faire des tas de rencontes
inventé par une self Mad woman qui a
peut-être souffert ce merveilleux petit
appareil possède plusieurs fréquences
les fréquences ce sont des des
fréquences
hommes-femm ce sont des fréquences euh
homosexuelles des fréquences lesbiennes
et des fréquences couple échangiste vous
pouvez vous tromper de fréquences en
manipulant l'appareil et alors attention
aux surprises
oui bonjour bonjour
bonjour dites-moi on est sur la même
frécance oh bah écoutez non non non
vraiment écoutez